suppose you wrote an application called
chocolate chooser that implements a
chocolate back-end API using endpoints
the app ID for chocolate chooser is choc
app ID the client ID is 123 choc now
let's suppose someone else writes an
application call let's say devastating
desserts that uses JavaScript to access
a chocolate API the app ID is dev
desserts and the client ID is 123 dev
des and this devastating desserts
application is all about the UI so it
doesn't have any back-end API so now
let's think about the API definition for
chocolate API in the chocolate chews or
application so here we've got the API
definition the name is chocolate API
versions v1 the Scopes is emailed this
basically means that we're going to be
using the users email it's up to you to
tell us what with the client ID be here
and go ahead and just enter a specific
value